can we move on to jenna dewan um she
hosted world of dance for a bit
she did she did the first two seasons
and i have to say she is the most
amazing human being just the most
beautiful light i love her i love jenna
wow that is so cool because in this
exclusive clip from robin roberts new
show
jenna reveals how getting the call to
that show went down during one of the
toughest times in her life
lauren zema has the story with world of
dance i had never hosted anything in my
life and jennifer lopez calls me and
says i think you should host a show
we're starting in two days
i had just separated in my relationship
so
no one knew it but i was dealing with
that and i had to go
the next day it was literally the next
day revelations like this
are what you can expect on robin's
stripped-down new show
turning the tables with robin roberts
it's kind of like the weekend version of
robin
it's not the robin behind the desk at
gma totally unscripted
it's your show it's just me
with some incredible women and hoping
that
something that we're saying can make you
feel like you're
you're not alone the news veteran is
bringing together everyone from
hollywood legends like jamie lee curtis
and debbie allen to sports icon billie
jean king in the four-part series
streaming wednesday on disney plus i
can't believe i'm going to share this
okay good luck robin gets emotional
herself
opening up about when she came out to
the public and being there the moment
her mom
passed away in 2012. i was caught off
guard
that i shared as much as i did what do
you think your mom would think
of the fact that you are about to debut
this show and changing lives of women
as your mom changed your life for you yo
hey lauren
that was so sweet
that's so sweet how you said that oh
gosh
um my mom loved conversation
i think she'd be cheering me on from her
heavenly balcony that's what i think
you